[Music]
you came back not once not twice not
three times but four times in the match
and even took the lead is this what you
play for this kind of struggle when you
play against fantastic players like
magnets I didn't take the losses too
hard and it probably helped me come back
um pretty much after every game I lost I
won the next one so so yeah I guess I
was in good mindset unfortunately you
can't have any real weaknesses when
you're playing against Magnus and and
the last game was it was a very big
weakness and he pounced on it so just
because you're fighting role doesn't you
have to keep fighting wall to the end
it's not enough to just do it you know a
few times but you have to keep going
until the match is over and and I wasn't
able to but you have been tremendous
throughout this entire match and not
just this one but before you come back
against Wesley then you you just played
Herculean chess do you feel like this
might set the the doubters to rest the
haters would think that maybe you don't
play well at quick return controls no I
don't think so I think that the haters
will think what they what they will just
regardless of results and it doesn't
really bother me I mean I have
confidence in my own ability so I don't
really care what other people think